okay
i'm gonna check this trap here
i see something moving in there
what the hell is that
something's growling
it's like this deep
okay
ah
there's something in there
i i have a feeling
i know exactly what it is
think there's an electric eel in there
[Music]
right there
do you see that
[Music]
i got a slithering eel in there
electric eels can produce a shocking
jolt of over 650 volts
it's just like sticking your finger
right into a light
socket it's an adaptation the eels have
for hunting prey
navigating in murky water and
self-defense
okay
get out of there
ah
look at that that is an electric eel
do you hear that
that's crazy
okay
come on go back in the water go back in
the water
they're very mysterious
very ugly but
amazing animal
their whole bodies are just full of fat
like hardly any muscle at all and um
yeah as far as eating them goes there
are very few tribes
that uh eat them
i have tried them myself they're just
like lard goo
gelatin yeah it's not nice not nice
thankfully the eel isn't the only fish
caught in the trap
the catfish is alive but it can't move
because it's been stunned by that eel
basically they were trapped together
oh man
big meaty fish
[Music]
you